act of kindness acts of generosity
is how simple it is to make people feel
good
i was walking down the streets of new
york city
and a guy walking in front of me his
backpack opened and a bunch of paper
fell out on the
on the street i didn't think much of it
i bent down
i gathered up the papers handed them
back to him and pointed out that his his
bag had opened
now in our bodies there's a chemical
called oxytocin oxytocin is responsible
for all the warm and fuzzies unicorns
and rainbows
it's responsible for all the warm
feelings and connectedness
we have with each other friendship love
huge amounts of oxytocin surge through a
woman's body as she gives birth
this is what is responsible for the
mother child bond oxytocin binds human
beings
there are many ways to get oxytocin
one of them is acts of kindness and acts
of generosity
it feels good when we do something nice
for someone it feels good when someone
does something nice
for us on this particular day i did
something
for someone with no expectation of
anything in return i got a little surge
of oxytocin
i felt good he turned to me and he said
thank you it feels nice when someone
does something for us with no
expectation of anything in return
he felt good i walked to the end of the
street i'm waiting to cross the street
and a total stranger who happened to be
standing next to me said i saw what you
did back there that was really cool
as it turns out witnessing an act
of generosity releases oxytocin
and he felt good and the best part about
oxytocin is the more oxytocin we have in
our bodies
the more generous we become it is
mother nature's way of trying
desperately to get us to look after each
other
i can guarantee you that that man who
witnessed what i did
did something nice for somebody that day
simply because he
saw someone do something nice for
somebody that day
so what if we commit to do something
nice for someone
with no expectation of anything in
return imagine what happens at work
imagine what happens at home imagine
what happens with our friends
but it must be genuine
you